the adult novelty Expo is sort of a mini
CES for sex toys it's part of AVN's
annual porn industry convention in Vegas
to get a grip on this market we went
straight to designer
Ethan Imboden he founded the innovative
award-winning sex product company Jimmy
Jane and is now head of venture design
at frog she was kind of an expert we
walked from booth to booth with Ethan
and he picked out the most interesting
toys of the expo and gave us his tape
design is an incredibly powerful tool
for shaping the products environments
and services around us when evaluating a
product concept developers often focus
on one this is a product that people
will buy - is there a technology that we
could leverage here that will improve
its performance but they often forget
the third and arguably most important
question does it deliver a meaningful
experience will be considering all three
of these when we look at products today
this is the aura to buy lilo this
product is intended to simulate oral sex
with this nub which can move back and
forth or rotate we've seen this nub sort
of action before but I think it's
implemented here really nicely in a very
compact design the main issue here is
that this Jack where you charge the
product is a little bit too close to
where the actions gonna happen and I
think that's problematic I think this is
a product that despite a couple of
drawbacks will be successful for them
because it's an example of a technology
that's really in the service of a
superior experience this next product is
from a brand called Spock gum and this
is the gaga it is a combination of one
vibrator and to a camera so essentially
this is a vibrating endoscope I don't
think that I am that interested in
endoscopy as sort of a bedroom sport
this is really a technology lead idea
perhaps a solution in search of a
problem many people begin exploring
their sexuality by masturbating in the
tub or in the shower this product called
bubble love takes that to the next level
water is sucked up into this device here
and ejected along with air here
performing a bit of a water jet that you
can position within your tub this is
something that people are familiar with
but it makes that whole experience much
more practical than perhaps straddling a
faucet on the technology side I think
it's actually pretty great the
experience is where it really wins but I
think where this can really excel is
with another design iteration where it's
really about you and your body as
opposed to well a bunch of attachments
and other accessories this is a product
from njoy it's a stainless steel dildo
here's another product this is a small
anal plug this is solid steel and is
made with incredible precision
incredible craftsmanship and represents
a very different approach to the market
so enjoy lands in a sort of unique spot
in our framework technology isn't always
necessary to make a winning product
they're providing a great experience for
those in that niche and the technology
itself well maybe that's just brand and
quality the sex products industry has
been isolated by taboos for decades one
of the most useful lessons that I took
from my time in this industry was the
importance of defining the experience
first then employing design and
technology as a means to that end
rather than the other way around design
is an incredibly powerful tool for
shaping the sorry I'm just not coming in
right now
you